A potentially historic
winter storm is pounding
parts of the Great Lakes region
to people in New York's Erie County died
after suffering cardiac events
related to clearing snow.
Officials warn
that the storm could be life
threatening and have called on residents
to be prepared
Right now, we do have a travel ban
in South Buffalo.
We have a travel advisory throughout
the rest of Buffalo.
And we're asking people
if you don't need to go out.
If travel is not necessary.
Please stay at home so snow
plows can do their job.
While the winter storm has canceled
flights, halted traffic on major roadways
and knocked out power
as temperatures plunge.
Polo Sandoval has the story from Buffalo,
New York.
Yeah, we got some snow.
Heavy snowfall, thunder, lightning.
A potential historic
snowstorm is pummeling
areas surrounding
the Great Lakes
with western New York State
in the bull's eye. It's a little deep
Oh, my God.
The storm already dumped around
four feet of
snow south of Buffalo, prompting the NFL
to move the Buffalo Bills.
A Sunday game
to Detroit Highmark Stadium,
their usual home in Orchard Park,
left completely covered in white.
And the storm is expected to hit
the city hard on Friday night.
The National Weather
Service and New York officials
warning that the snowfall
will produce life
threatening conditions into the weekend
can turn very quickly.
This is a very unpredictable storm.
Even with the warnings
some people in Buffalo
don't seem too worried.
We live in Buffalo. It's expected.
That's all I could say.
We've been through this before.
It's not to me, it's no big deal.
But my family wants everything done.
Officials reminding people
to stay inside and off
the roads saying
there is a travel ban
in South Buffalo
with many flights
in and out of the region canceled.
Please stay indoors.
Do not go out
unless it is an absolute emergency.
National Weather Service forecasters
explained
lake effect
snow is fueling this extraordinary storm
that occurs when cold air blows over
warmer lake water
picking up more moisture
and leading to higher snow
amounts down stream
Climate experts
warn water
temperatures in the Great Lakes
grow increasingly warmer each year,
shortening the length of time
ice covers the surface during the winter.
I just want to remind everybody
that there is a lake effect
warning still in effect.
So this thing is still moving.
So we need to still take this series.
Polo Sandoval, CNN, Buffalo, New York.
CNN meteorologist Derek Van Dam
joins us now
live from the CNN
Weather Center
with more on all this Derek.
Leyla, these snow totals
I'm about to show
you are just mind boggling.
But you've got to see this
almost a elevated view time
lapse of a snow squall.
This is the lake effect snow band
moving over downtown Buffalo earlier
on Friday.
And you can
see the extreme whiteout conditions
that just basically inundate
and take over the city.
This is a very narrow
band of heavy snowfall.
We're talking
three upwards of five inches per hour
within that snow band,
but it's only a ten mile wide snow band.
So dependent on where it's located.
That's the location
that's getting the heaviest
snowfall at that particular time.
Here's the snowfall totals as promised.
That is an impressive,
incredible amount of snow.
We're talking about nearing record
breaking territory
for the state of New York.
That has to be officially closed
from the National Weather Service
and analyzed by some of the
the the measuring apparatuses
that are ongoing here, really
for all these various locations.
But nonetheless,
that is just
a significant amount of snow.
And it is significantly dangerous,
especially for households and businesses.
There, just because of the sheer
weight of the snow.
We've done the math for you.
You can double check my math
if you'd like.
You can follow me on Twitter
and correct me if I'm wrong on this one.
But if we're looking at an average
square footage
of a house, 2000 square feet or so,
you multiply that
by four feet of snow on average,
depending on where we're talking about in
and around Buffalo.
That equates to nearly £50,000
on top of your roof.
That is like having ten
SUVs piled up on top of your building.
That,
of course, could lead to some collapse
or failed roofs.
And that is obviously dangerous,
not to mention
what's happening on the roadways.
We have still over
6 million Americans
under these winter weather alerts,
including Michigan.
But I'm really focusing our attention
downwind of Lake Erie
and Lake Ontario
because this is the area
that has been battered
for a good part of the past 48 hours.
And now that heavy snow
band moving directly over the downtown
area of Buffalo
so they're getting hit very hard
right now.
This is a three hour loop,
but I want to go back 24 hours
because I want you to see
almost that
firehose of
snow that continues
to oscillate
north and south, depending
on the exact direction of the wind.
That's what I was talking about,
that narrow, heavy band of snowfall.
It is so imperative and so critical
where that wind direction is,
because that determines
who sees the whiteout conditions,
who sees the heaviest amounts of snow.
So the question on everyone's minds,
how much more snow is still to come?
Well,
we have the potential for over
two feet of additional
snow through Sunday evening
across the Watertown region
into the northern Syracuse suburbs
and Buffalo
another foot
to a foot
and a half of additional snowfall
for you.
These snowfall totals are tremendous
and they could be going down in the
record books. Time will tell.